le 3 novembre les américains éliront le
locataire la maison blanche
un bail de 4 à débutant le 20 janvier
2000 vt au congrès les 435 sièges de la
chambre des représentants seront
renouvelés pour une période de deux ans
sierre des postes de sénateurs seront en
jeu des mandats de six ans aux états sur
50 choisiront également un nouveau
gouverneur ainsi que deux territoires
porto rico et les samoa américaines
de nombreux états tiendront à la même
date des élections législatives
l'élection de novembre c'est aussi
l'occasion de référendums
par exemple une ou deux et se prononcera
sur la légalisation du cannabis
récréatif
tout cela s'ajoute à des courses à la
mairie comme un témoin hynix et honolulu
et des élections judiciaire puisque de
dizaines de juges seront élus à
différents niveaux
cela donne des bulletins complexe
difficile à déchiffrer comme celui ci
lors de l'élection 2016
pl
[Musique]